wir waren heute in den eigenen bogen
offendorf haben früher mein haselnuss
ausgenommen dann hier am ende zwei teile
eingeschnitzt und in der mitte eine
leichte führung die schnuller
aufgespannt daneben einen dünnen zweig
zu einem pfeil angespritzt mit dem
kleinen schlitten drin und sack haben
wir den bogen
[Musik]
theoretisch zumindest jetzt ist es
wieder nicht fertig denn ich bin
komplett übertriebenen bogen bauen der
auch wirklich funktioniert was er
wahrscheinlich im handel schon gesehen
haben mögen werden zwar heute fast
ausschließlich als sportgerät genutzt
waren aber tatsächlich mit die ältesten
waffen der menschheitsgeschichte die
ersten gab es schon vor 70.000 jahren
die ersten schwerter hingegen erst vor
6000 der einfache bogen hat sich aber
extrem weiterentwickelt zu sogenannten
recurve und compound bogen die meist aus
karbon gebaut werden das so einen bogen
heute 300 meter weit schießen kann
konnte man sich vor 70.000 jahren
bestimmt auch nicht vorstellen im
gegensatz zu den modernen maschinell
gefertigten bögen wird bei meinem der
fokus aber auf kunstvollem design und
mir möglichst kunstvoll im handwerk
liegen weswegen ich mir erstmal für 220
euro das ist absolut edle schnitt
gekauft hat aber natürlich muss ich mir
überlegen wie unsere bogen überhaupt
aussehen soll und da habe ich mich von
dancing impact inspirieren lassen von
denen auch dieses video unterstützt werk
genthin impact ist ein open world
adventure game das ist sowohl mobil als
auch am pc und auf konsole spielen
können den ganzen im feld gibt es
spannende kämpfe folgen challenges und
eine riesige atemberaubende welt zu
erkunden und eben auch mega heftige
fantasy bögen besonders china quasi
muhlack trat deswegen werden versuchen
das kann geteilt in echt zu bauen zum
dritten geburtstag von menschen den park
kommen jetzt übrigens die neue map sowie
ruhe ins spiel so mehr ist inspiriert
vom mittleren osten und südasiatischen
kulturen muss die landschaft bietet
sowohl wüsten also auch wälder mit dem
kot in der infobox bekommt ja 60 prima
james und fünf abenteurers wollte also
klickt auf den link in der beschreibung
und ladet euch gänschen im hack center
als erstes haben wir uns überlegt wie
wir so ein fantasy bogen überhaupt in
die realität umsetzen und einen plan
ausgeklügelt die allermeisten bürgern
bekommen ihre spannung aus dem bogen wie
unser haselnuss bogen der sich durch den
zug an der sehne biegt und dann da bloß
lassen die ich nur nach vorne schnellen
lässt so ein krasses design lässt sich
mit flexiblen materialien aber kaum
umsetzen unsere idee war selbst dass wir
den bogen einfach star machen dass die
zugkraft über so eine umlenkrolle und im
gummiband erzeugt wird ähnlich diesem
beispiel jetzt ist natürlich die frage
aus welchem material so gebogen werden
und ich persönlich bevorzuge da ganz
klar holz schön ist dann auch weil ich
bock aufschlitzen hab jetzt fragt ihr
euch hier bei der bogen ist ja blau und
holz ja normalerweise nicht das stimmt
habe ich noch gedacht und ich will ich
will gar nicht einfach über lackieren
deswegen werden bei zu nehmen um so eine
geile oberfläche zu haben wie bei diesen
coolen er getan für diese getan wird in
der region verwendet weil auf dem hellen
holz die farbe gut zur geltung kommt
deswegen mache ich das einfach auch wir
brauchen also eine menge an also ab zum
baumarkt kann ich
die jungs haben zwar einige ist für
andere projekte bekommen hahn gab es
aber leider nicht holz zu bekommen das
nicht gerade in standard brett oder
platte in einer standard holzart ist ist
gar nicht so leicht deshalb habe ich den
guten tischlermeister und youtuber
kollegen jonas winkler gefragt wo wir
das am besten her bekommen worauf er zu
meiner überraschung kurzerhand den alten
dicken hobel angeschmissen hat und uns
ruckzuck fünf richtig geile ahornboden
vorbeigeschickt hat
einfach krank holte so was schönes
foul an jonas in seinem shop ist auch in
der aktuell aus gekauft um sogar dass er
noch ein paar kohlen für unseren bogen
aufgetrieben hat der pianist eine
schablone von der bogenform in cad zu
erstellen
[Musik]
diese dann in 3 d drucker zu drucken
und dann die formen zuerst gruppen in
unserer neuen bandsäge auszuschalten
[Musik]
und nach der bandsäge mit dem kündigt
reeser eins zu eins die form der
schablone in unseren kopieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wer wirklich unfassbar riesig und sind
schon extrem geil aus wir wollen mich
jetzt allerdings mit den ganzen
schnitzwerk zeuge nicht mehr extra für
diese projekte kauft hat an den osten
bogen wagt test ich das erste mal an
einem übungs stück also man klickt mit
dem reisen heißt das glaube ich echt
eine menge holz weg
also das ist schon mal sehr sehr cool
mit diesem argument kann man dann eben
noch alle an andere sachen machen zum
beispiel kann man mit dem hier nochmal
so coolen reinmachen
das ist echt geil
ok nachdem ich jetzt weil er absolut
unnötig an diesem ab drei stück hier rum
geschnitzt hat kommt jetzt mal das stück
weg und jetzt kommt das richtige
holzstück ran wir auch so ein 3d modell
von diesen kompletten boden einmal im 3d
druck ausgedrückt das heißt ich kann mir
das jetzt einmal anschauen und sie
überall wohin welche verklungen sind und
welche vertiefungen und erhöhungen genau
das gibt es ja überall eine rundung
so befindet eingezeichnet und alles was
jetzt an gesprächen das muss einmal ein
bisschen vertieft werden und ich würde
sagen das könnte ich sogar mit der
oberfläche machen und damit habe ich
jetzt einmal überall wo es geschickt ist
ungefähr einer halben zentimeter ab
[Musik]
gott also das muss auf jeden fall und
hat gesagt wenn jetzt alles voll mit
staub es entsteht die sauereien meines
lebens die ganze werkstatt ist voll mit
spänen
das ergebnis kann sich aber sehen lassen
den rest mache jetzt mit bloßen händen
also besser gesagt mit messer die vorher
gesagt jetzt quasi dass diese dinge hier
einmal schön abgerundet werden müssen
und dass man jetzt können wir mal dass
hier nehmen einfach mal so eine schöne
phase dran machen
das bringt das klingt sicherlich schön
auf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist fertig geschnitzt wer also ich
persönlich kann das hat richtig spaß zu
machen total gern mit diesem wechsel
cleverness hat im großen und ganzen
eigentlich doch besser funktioniert als
erwartet jetzt muss nur noch geschliffen
werden das könnte jetzt in der hand
machen will allerdings ewig dauern darum
hoffe ich das nicht drum rum kommt
nächsten hierfür dieses schleifgerät der
kontext also ein schwamm gekauft wenn
man jetzt hier so eine schleife problem
kann und dann ist der sus oft dass man
damit theoretisch auch kurven schleifen
kann so soll das muss ihnen nicht gut
funktioniert gar nicht mal komplett
schlecht aber ich glaube ich muss ein
bisschen nacharbeiten mit wer womit
eigentlich
somit der handwerker noch ein bisschen
nach
jetzt war unser erstes größeres teil
fertig es wird mal zeit ein bisschen
bilanz zu ziehen und wenn wir uns jetzt
noch diese rolle hier dran vollständig
bin nur ankommen wird finde ich ist das
schon echt ziemlich nah am original
draht was das will ich noch fehlt ist
hier drüber dieses wilde weiße gefieder
ähnliche zeug und dafür habe ich
absichtlich keine hormone gemacht wer
hinter zeuge ich weiß ich kann holz nie
und nimmer irgendwie weiß werben ohne
das ist komplett über lackier und damit
die holzmaserung kaputt macht es wäre
schade und sollten wir auch absolut
extrem aufwändig darum wird das einfach
3d ähnlich wie hier nur viel größer
[Musik]
während dieser teil gedruckt wird
kümmere ich mich um die umlenkrollen die
habe ich in cad bereits einmal
nachmodelliert und spezielle flächen in
unserer bogenform eingeplant auf die
dann draufgeschraubt werden können so
wird also die sehne im bogen gespannt
und über eine zug feder oder ein
gummiband das hier an dieser silbernen
öse befestigt wird entsteht die spannung
also hoffentlich da diese echte
umlenkrolle aktuell noch zu lange es
werden die enten mit der flex gekürzt
[Musik]
die weg gekürzten löcher anschließend
neu gebohrt hier habe ich übrigens
getestet wie stabil eine drei zentimeter
schraube ist und die antwort ist ja vier
davon reichen also auf jeden fall
[Musik]
und er ist riesig ja echt ganz gut
funktioniert nicht gedacht dass er das
in einem zug so durchzieht das ist
wirklich die größte träger wenn ich
jemals gemacht habe aber das ist noch
nicht mal alles da kommt
das zweite mal größer sein ganzer kopf
das kommt irgendwie durch und dann wird
sie dort versteckt
und das hält auch richtig geil es ist
extrem krass oh mein gott ganz kaum
erwarten bis es heute endlich mal blau
ist wenn der sack ist dass wir zu krass
aussehen aber sagen bin ich erstmal
zufrieden wie heftig das einmal aus
nichts da fehlen jetzt allerdings noch
einige 3d drucker hier oben zum beispiel
die wir gerade schon gedrückt vor allem
muss aber auch der gesamte boden hier
fertig geschnitzt werden bis morgen denn
da haben wir den boden schießplatz den
ich gerade also gekriegt habe weil alle
aktuell komplett aus gebieten also
epische baum anteile
[Musik]
jetzt wo diese kräfte fertig ist muss
das ganze noch verlangt und das wissen
schwierig der gerade schräge teile zu
verlangen ist immer so dass ich manchmal
hier allein drauf um eine kugel spur
[Musik]
die fliege ist mir auf den leim gegangen
und das ist allererste mal dass dinge
fest sparen
jetzt kann ich quasi das teilt hier
dagegen drücken soll jetzt ist dass ich
ja da weise hier wohl angespannt
nicht sogar wie ich dachte ich heute zum
jubel rein so der leyen wir wieder
runter gekratzt
da sollen die bilder ist die
konstruktion überhaupt diese fähigkeit
zusammengeschustert haben absolut
schwierig das teil explodiert auch jeden
augenblick sieht auf jeden fall sehr
professionell aus so der leyen ist
hoffentlich truppen
gaddafis ist richtig in szene fallen da
wird also der wirt ultra beauty shit
seine aufgabe ist jetzt das teil hier
bündig zu machen
[Musik]
weil wir am ende mit dem bogen wie
gesagt auch zum testen auf irgendwas
schießen wollen baut pascal während ich
hier im bogenbau bin ziele aber nicht
irgendwelche ziele sondern bewegliche
ziele in grenchen impact gibt es nämlich
die sogenannten block i flow dies wenn
man mit denen im spiel integriert
fliegen diese drei balon ähnlichen
zielen nach hinten und man muss sie in
einer bestimmten zeit mit dem bogen
abschießen und schaltet damit besondere
thronen mit waffen artefakten und
materialien zum leveln frei aber
natürlich kann man den bogen in gentian
impact nicht nur für solche challenges
nutzen sondern auch für kämpfe je
nachdem mit welchem charakter man den
bogen nutzt gibt es verschiedene
animationen was das gameplay recht
abwechslungsreich gestaltet und somit
den wirklich funktioniert eine flotte
partie in echt nachgebaut zuerst
brauchen wir einen ast mit drei enden
und da wir diesen haselnuss kerl
loswerden wollen trägt sich das ganz gut
so und dann hatte ich noch nie komplett
wird die idee den fuß des vogelhäuschens
mit zu verwenden wird
[Musik]
die magnete die ich ja gerade dank gäbe
sind übrigens dazu da damit diese blaue
ballons wie beim block i thought i erst
am ast halten aber später von einer
heftigen gerätschaft die pascal gebaut
hat nach hinten in die luft gezogen
werden können sobald ich mich nähere und
sie sich dann weiter leicht hin und
herbewegen genau wie menschen impact die
luftballons werden dafür an einer schnur
gebunden die am boden über einen motor
und mehrere umlenkrollen hin und her
bewegt werden kann und das war echt viel
arbeit diese antriebswelle durchlief zum
beispiel drei verschiedene versionen bis
die perfekten grip an der schnur hatte
bevor wir das komplette zusammenspiel
aber in action sehen muss erstmal der
bogen fertig gebaut werden soja wird sie
nach durchgemacht und noch geschliffen
und geschnitzt zusammen mit sophie
bezieht man noch einmal zum letzten mal
die natur lockt ja da konnte ich mich
jetzt gleich geile beize drauf das ding
wird jetzt einmal blau
ich habe so was noch nie gemacht um
hoffe ich jetzt einfach mal dass es
klappt okay das war richtig dumm aber
halb so wild jetzt ist einmal der
komplette bogenbau ein gefährt
das konzert ist frei ich bin gespannt
wie das später lackiert aussieht ja okay
so ein bisschen viel lack vielleicht war
die maße und kommt ist nicht geld und
damit doch das ist gerade mal die erste
lackschicht nachdem diese für fünf
stunden getrocknet hat wird sie noch mal
leicht abgeschliffen und eine zweite
schicht aufgetragen
[Musik]
während die zweite und hoffentlich
letzte schichten und trocknet teste ich
den entspannungs mechanismus da der
bogen selbst die also gut wie gar nicht
biegsam ist generieren wir die spannung
über einen expander und eine umlenkrolle
und wie es aussieht funktioniert das
sogar wirklich
übel kreis das echt geil dann geht es an
die mechanik
fest
das hält ruhig mit einmalig nur nicht
nur schädliche durch
und schon ist die erstes alle fälle
jetzt machen auch die zweite hälfte
erledigt jetzt wieder bogen ja mehr oder
weniger gespannt das ist nach es kommt
noch das teil hin auf lassen später der
paul dorf gelegt wird so fertig und
jetzt will ich seinen kasten rein ich
lade dem pfeil oder kann wie man das
nennt
war okay das geht tatsächlich
besser als gedacht so probieren auch in
anderen fall
ja der ist perfekt geil einkommens noch
die ornamente dran letzte gold elemente
[Musik]
oha
wie weit und wie treffsicher diese bild
die konstruktion wirklich schießt test
märz an unserem selbst gebauten floß ii
und um niemanden zu verletzen und fahren
wir jetzt auf einen bogen schießplatz
ich war noch nie auf so einem platz und
ich finds echt cool dass wir jetzt mal
einen szenenwechsel haben um den bogen
test möglichst realistisch zu gestalten
bei ganz schön im projekt wird es mit
den sieben einzigartigen region mit
ihrem detailreichen designs und
vielfältigen interaktionsmöglichkeiten
auch nie langweilig jede region hat eine
eigene kultur architektur kleidung und
die menschen für eine unterschiedliche
dialoge mit euch besonders die musik im
spiel lässt ein richtig tief in die
spanten storylines eintauchen und macht
die spielwelt zu lebendig nicht ohne
grund hat ganzen impact verschiedene
awards gewonnen wie zum beispiel das
meistdiskutierte spiel auf reddit in
2021 weil die community einfach riesig
ist es ist komplett geil den ganzen
platz für uns alleine richtig cool
fielen dann auf jeden fall im bogenclub
oferdingen frau dass wir schießen dürfen
[Musik]
er hat im moment der wahrheit wenn ich
mit dem aqua simulator bogen die drei
tage jetzt von block i flow die treffen
und auf geht's egal ob ich da was
treffer es ist wirklich schwierig als
kommt mit dem bogen als das ist manchmal
den am boden der seite komplett los
so war das nicht geplant da war ja bitte
man hat ein bisschen links 3 das mich
jetzt mal passieren würde ist ob dies
überhaupt kaputt gehen wenn ich treffe
meine klaus
wurde steckt viel zu hart nach links mit
dem dann auch mal leichte
leichte design änderungen vor weil da
der pfeil immer angeschlagen hat
aber funktioniert schon besser es ist so
anstrengend wie
oh
mein gott ich war ein bisschen
beunruhigt ob das teil wirklich platzt
aber es hat auf jeden fall in treffer
gewertet der floating zloty ist bald
geschichte
also ich sag jetzt mal die perfekte form
zu machen das hier so ok ich probier's
mal
[Musik]
yello ist ob das geklappt hat ich hätte
niemals gedacht dass es jetzt augen auf
anhieb funktioniert sogar das ist krass
also die challenge auf jeden fall
gewonnen hat bisschen gedauert aber da
war richtig da richtig gute wahl für 12
auf den dritten mann jetzt auch spannend
wer ist wie weit ich mit dem bogen
wirklich maximal schießen kann wenn ich
komplett vollgas durch sie
gehe ich meistens fünf meter 10 meter 20
25 29 1 also 30 meter schuss der welt
weiß nicht ob das was aber für den bogen
der so komplett krank aussieht und eher
so aus als sollte ein echt eingebaut mit
funktioniert ohne magie ist es glaube
ich schon ordentlich in grenchen impact
bekommt man mit seinem treffer auf den
block die flotte übrigens eine seltene
truhe mit waffen artefakten und
materialien also wenn ihr lust bekommen
habt das auch mal zu probieren ladet
euch unbedingt ganzen impact runter und
macht euch auf die suche nach dem motiv
ließ der link dazu ist in der wieder
beschreibung und ich bin damit raus
macht's gut